the documents appear to include
sensitive information regarding the war
in Ukraine in particular U.S
intelligence assessments of the
performance of both the Ukrainian and
Russian forces the Pentagon has
confirmed that many of the documents
appear to be in the similar format used
to provide updates to senior leaders
which would imply the leaks occurred at
a high level I'm just not going to get
into uh the the specific specifics of
this Beyond saying what you've heard
others across the interagency say which
is that the Department of Defense and
the intelligence Community are reviewing
and assessing the validity of these
documents there is no question of course
that they present a risk to National
Security but I'm just not going to get
into specifics the leak of the documents
was first reported by the New York Times
and in addition to revealing
intelligence about the war in Ukraine
they also exposed the extent of U.S
eavesdropping on key allies including
Israel and South Korea
the reaction in capitals like Seoul has
been angry spilling over into the South
Korean National Assembly
we strongly regret that the top U.S
intelligence agency has been illegally
spying on allies like our country we
strongly demand a thorough investigation
and urge that similar incidents do not
occur
the White House is in a mode of full
damage control and the National Security
Council has confirmed that U.S officials
have been in touch with relevant allies
and partners given these disclosures in
the department of justices is leading a
criminal investigation so we're taking
this very very seriously there is uh
no uh excuse for these kinds of
documents to be in the public domain and
while the Department of Justice
continues its investigation into the
source of the leagues senior U.S
officials will not rule out the
possibility that more documents could be
made public
Anna Al Jazeera Washington